Okay, let's get into this guys. Welcome to the call. Obviously, we're going to be skipping
there's a few things that the some just small things that we were going to cover, but we're
not going to for time's sake. But long story short, I told you guys, I will just say this
really quick. I told you guys that we are going to be within the next two weeks going
to be talking about search volume, and we're going to be introducing the tool that we are
going to be using going forward, so that we can have a gold standard for search volume.
So keep an eye out for that. Other than that, we're going to we're going to get right into
this with Mr. Jason. I'll read Jason. Thanks for joining us also known as Donnie Dre. And
I have got seven questions for him. I'm going to see if I get through all of them. And then
also, Aaron, if you have questions, I'm gonna let you ask and anyone else that has questions
ask as well. So let's do it. So Jason, all read. Let's start really quick. Tell everybody
how much you are doing per month as of today. So I'm doing 13.8 K today. Beautiful. Assuming
I close that other deal, which can't count the chickens before they hatch. So 13.8 K
today should be at 14.8 K. But you know, is that the deal that we're talking about? They
ghosted you? Yeah, yeah. So that one I assumed was closed for some reason. But yeah, unless
you get a payment, don't assume it's closed. That is so true. You have no idea how true
that is. So 13.8 K. When did you start? Just to give everyone a little bit of context.
I bought into your program December or November of last year. But you know, you said that
you really started like actually properly started in January. Like you like actually
got into this in January. Yeah, that's when I really like got my shit together. And I
was like, dude, you have to go all in this. Like, there's no reason why you should be
chasing these SEO deals. So I just went, I just went all in, in January. And yeah, that's
when I really started getting this thing going. So before that, when you were you, I remember
that you were actually you do a little bit SEO. Yeah, yeah. Got it. And that's natural.
What were you doing before? And are you still doing it? I was doing SEO, but I was doing
SEO for before SEO. You were doing SEO before you even joined? Yeah, I was doing SEO for
about probably five or six months before I joined your program. Okay, okay. That's exactly
what happened to me. And sometimes, guys, it's okay. Sometimes you got to pay the bills.
We understand that. But you got to be careful that you do. You don't get stuck, stuck down
the wormhole of SEO. What did you think? Like to you, what was the hardest, the hardest,
what was the biggest or the biggest challenge with running SEO company? Oh, dude, there's
there's so many. Um, so first of all, I had quite a few female business owners, and I'm
not trying to like discriminate at all. But they literally wanted me to change the look
of their website almost every other day. I was spending more time at the desk trying
to make these business owners happy with just the looks of their website, not even getting
them results. Then I was spending at my nine to five job before I quit. So I felt like
I kind of just had this dream of walking away from the nine to five, but I walked straight
into this other prison cell basically. And it just wasn't working out for me. Yeah, that's
a tricky thing to happen to me. There's nothing wrong with SEO. There's nothing wrong with
using SEO to quit your job. But like for me, it was a prison cell because I never felt
confident that the money was going to be there. Yeah. And we made this hilarious or not we
Isaac did. He made this hilarious like meme of like, yeah, it's, it's oh, it's not Owen
Wilson. It's Tom Hanks or whatever. It's like when you're at SeaWorld and your $4,000 a
month client quits. And I was literally at SeaWorld and on like a vacation and we're
making around eight to nine top line. One of my clients was $4,000 a month. And that
person called me in the middle of SeaWorld. And I just knew when I saw the phone ring
that I was toast. And man, what a what a bad experience when you're about to go on a vacation
paid for by the client and they're telling you they're done. So that was when I was like,
I have to get out of this. That was that was mid summer 2019. And that's if you guys put the
timeline together was the end of 2019 when I really like almost quit doing this business,
which is funny because I really didn't even give this a proper chance. But anyway, long story
short. Yeah, and then tell us really quick, like what are some of the niches you're you don't have
to tell us everything. But what are some of the different niches that you're in?
I just listened to your advice and went straight into the tried and true. I'm still doing that.
Most of my deals are in concrete. Some of my deals are in tree service. The one I closed on
Sunday is is in tree service. I got a few niches that that I feel like have potential that I haven't
shared with people. But you know, that's for for another conversation. If I get 200,000 K,
I'll share it with you guys. So, you know, it's funny is an Aaron can tell you guys this is true.
Well, first of all, we just got Sanchezca. You guys probably saw the post just got a $1,700 a
month deal in artificial grass. This was on this is yesterday, actually. And she might have got it
on yesterday or Sunday. Anyway, so that's artificial grass. That's a tried and true niche. And then she
just found a really good area for concrete. And Aaron, you can even tell everyone I'm not lying
here. When I heard the name of the city, which you're not going to say, you better not say I
told I said now I don't believe it. You remember I said this is yesterday. I was like, now we're
gonna pull up some rush. Yeah, I was like, now we're not doing there's no way that area is open
for concrete. And because the city is really well known. And he's like, No, I've even looked at it
myself. And she started reading me the CPC. And she's like, I didn't believe it either. So for
those of you that are just like, Oh, my gosh, concrete's done or artificial grass down or
fencing is done. Okay. Keep complaining. So that's one of the questions I am going to actually I'm
going to jump to that one. Because it's crazy that you we can have the same training. Jason has the
same training as everybody else. He has the same coaching calls. He gets on there these he has the
same Facebook community. And for some reason, Jason's at $13,800 per month. And there's people
that are at zero that are sending me messages. And Aaron does this because he works with me directly.
There's people sending me messages that probably aren't on this call, because they're probably
busy thinking of excuses. But they're they're just blaming me, the training, the world,
the recession, the the the the rocks and the universe. And they they aren't making any money.
So I guess I'm going to jump towards near the end of one of the questions I was going to ask you,
which is, like, why do you why do you think you're having success? Or let me ask this one,
why aren't people having success that you are the same success that you are?
That's a good question. I, I think there's a lot of people who are
doing a lot better than I'm doing. I mean, wasn't
Yeah, but I'm saying for everyone else, and I appreciate your humility, but and there are people
that are crushing it. But you've also just kind of started. Right. Why? Why? Why are there some
people that are at zero right now? Or that are like, it's the most hardest thing to comprehend
how to get a deal? Like, why? It's the same thing. I can't figure it out.
Yeah, I understand the question. They're just not taking imperfect action. You have to take the
action. If you're not going to pick up the phone and call a business owner, and at least learn off
of that call from the very get go, you're not going to go anywhere. And Nick told us from the
very beginning, follow his step by step process. And you will close deals. So what I did is I went,
I created my Google ads, I generated leads. Next thing I needed to do is, okay, now I need to go
and learn how to hook a business owner. And I literally just followed your steps, Nick.
Next thing I knew I was on a closing call with a business owner.
Just not imperfect action, in my opinion. What do you think, Aaron?
I mean, I agree. Like, you talked about it before, you have the end goal.
You just got to do the steps that lead up to it. I mean, that's it. It is an equation.
I agree. I mean, I agree. That's definitely, that's 100% a part of it. I'm trying to think
if there's anything else. But it is bonkers from my perspective as somebody. And I remember, guys,
I hope you know, I remember being the person that was at zero, watching other people make money.
And when I'm not making money, instead of just owning it, it's so easy as a human to make excuses
and to try to blame everybody else and go, well, yeah, but those people don't have full-time
doorknocking jobs. Those people don't have kids. Those people this, those people that,
and then all of a sudden you want to start like, just pretending it doesn't work and you look for
excuses for why it doesn't work instead of just thinking, maybe I'm the freaking problem.
And then finally you hit this point, for those of us that are finally pull our heads out,
is for me, I remember seeing people post deals and I would get so pissed off and not in a jealous
way. Finally, I was just like, I would, I would see a deal and then I would click on the profile
and I was like, dude, I know I'm more talented than that person. Like I could just tell.
And I was like, if that person could do it, then I, and I hope you guys, when you see me,
the fact that I'm, I really, really, really am a very average person. It should inspire you that
anybody can do this. Because if you knew me, if you knew where I came from, if you knew the school,
I went to, if you knew my testing scores, dude, I'm not Mr. Like super smart. I think I'm just
Mr. Persistent and that's the truth. So I do agree though, imperfect action. Those of us that are
willing to be, to look stupid. I heard Jesse Insler say this on like a short the other day,
it's like the moment that you gave yourself permission to feel stupid is the most freeing
thing ever. And the problem is some of you guys want to look so cool and so tough and it's like,
dude, just pick up the phone. Everyone's going to say some stupid stuff. I've said things on calls
that I'm like, Oh, that was bad, dude. You know, and I have dude. So anyway, okay. That said guys,
Jason, why did you actually get into this industry? So what, like, what are you trying to achieve with
this business model? Why did you get into rank and rent specifically? What was the thing that
you're like, you know, for like, just for giving an example for me, I wanted to be able to travel
and like, make his like, make internet money that I wasn't tied to one location. That was the biggest
thing for me. What's the reason that you got into, you know, this vehicle?
Yeah, mine are pretty similar to yours, Nick. When I first branched off and just burnt the ships and
started doing SEO, I, me and my wife created a vision board and we had all of these things
planned out. Like I promised her I would take her to all of these, these places to visit and stuff
like that. And my family was like, you know, bragging about their second vacation of the year.
And I hated that so much. I was like, dude, I'm not just going to save every year and try and go on
one vacation once a year. That's the stupidest thing ever. So we made goals where we are going
to travel whenever we want. And that's kind of what we're shooting for. But I also want to build
my dream home. I want to watch my kids take their first steps. I want to watch my kids say their
first words and working a nine to five job or even just spending all day in the office
isn't going to cut it for me. I want to be able to step outside and do things on my own terms.
So really, I just want a simple life, to be honest, and get paid in my sleep.
Pretty simple, to be honest.
I love that, dude. It's kind of like, what was I just listening to? I can't remember. I heard
something similar. But like, as you were saying, I was thinking, like, instead of, instead of just
living a life where you're just living for your next vacation, like, I don't, this just probably
sounds cheesy, but like, you can actually make your life a vacation in the sense that like,
you every day, and I kind of feel like I'm not completely there, but I'm close because
I have done, I have been so many places this year. And I mean, it's business as usual. Like,
I do do a little bit of work. You guys have seen me do Zoom calls from all over the world, but like,
I've been, I've been to London twice. I've been to Paris Fashion Week. I've been to Dubai.
I just was in Miami. I've been to LA. I've been to San Diego. I've been to Africa. I'm going to
Dubai again. I'm going to Daffer. I mean, and always just business as usual. It's just because
I want to, and I can, and why not. So, but here's the cool part, guys, is like, you don't have to
want to travel. Some of you guys don't want to travel. And that's completely cool, too.
Some of you guys want to sit at home and mow your lawn and put, you know, garden gnomes in your
front yard and, you know, drink sweet tea and all that stuff. And that is a cool life as well.
But you get to design it how you want to design it. So I was just curious for you what, what it
was. So that's awesome, dude. By the way, I'm curious, did you grow up like that? Or was it
like you grew up dad nine to five and that's why you feel like maybe that's why you want it's
because it's not what you had or is what you had and you want it as well? No, really. I grew up,
my family has worked the same job their entire life. So my dad started a cabinet company
and they all just work their same nine to five job. They, they look at it as job security and
they actually, you know, were like, dude, Jason, what the heck are you doing, bro? Like you're
getting scammed. You're paying somebody to teach you. Why not go get a college degree, if anything,
you know, that, that mindset that so many of the people in the country have, which is
complete BS, in my opinion. But really, it's just like, I don't want to be like everybody else.
I want to live a life on my own terms. You know, hearing people talk about, yeah, like their,
their first vacation of the year and, and they're all talking about how they're looking forward to
their next vacation 12 months from now. It just doesn't sit right with me. Like I want to be
taking phone calls on the golf course. I actually just went and bought some golf clubs just so I
can go in and just get into golfing because that's something I've always wanted to do,
but never had time. So, uh, so yeah, for you, bro. Um, for some reason, making money
on the golf course is a special money. It's, it slaps different. My first, my very ironically,
my very first money from this business was on the golf course. I've shared the story.
I was on this golf course. I remember everything. It was, it was, I know it was summer. Um, it was
about mid summer. It was 2000 is actually early. This is, I, this is before, I think it's even,
no, this is after that sidetracked. Maybe it was before, but anyway, it wasn't much. And it was a,
it was, everything was wrong. It was a paperly deal, but I was on a, a South gate golf course
and, um, I was on the second, I was in the, I was on hole 10, the back nine. I hit a really good
drive, which never happens. And, uh, yeah, dude, I was going, uh, I think I had, I literally think
I had a seven iron. I just, how much I remember seven iron and all of a sudden I heard this noise
on my phone or I hit, I don't know. I hit my second shot and I checked my phone and I was like,
dude, I just made a hundred dollars. And it was just a hundred dollars, right? Cause I was getting
paid per phone call. And, um, I remember being like, dude, I've made it. And that a hundred
dollars was so much better than I felt. I think that a hundred dollars was sweeter than the
million dollars I made in 2020. It's, it's a, it's the golf money's different, bro. So yeah, good,
good choice. Good choice. I love it. Okay. Let's talk about the last deal that you closed really
quick. Um, how much, what was the niche? How much like, so how much was it for thousand dollars,
thousand dollars per month, thousand clean thousand dollars, uh, concrete. No tree service.
This one's tree service. Okay. Tree service. I was supposed to have closed too in that same night,
but that one person slipped away. So. Gosh dang it. And there's still a chance, but yeah,
I would just write it off mentally. Um, how much did you spend on ads to how many leads did you
send them? So these guys, I ended up sending them five total. Uh, one came through actually,
no, it was four, four total. And on the closing call, I let them know. I said, Hey, one just
barely came through, assuming that we move forward together. Then I'll hand it over. It's not no big
deal, bro. That's a great thing to do, by the way, if you guys have a closing call scheduled,
you feel like they've, they've either closed the deal or they're interested. Use that as,
as a carrot. Don't just go ahead and give it to them before the call. Say, Hey, I actually,
Hey, I'm looking forward to our call. Um, where you're good to go. Right? Yeah. Okay. Cool. Awesome.
By the way, I had this really juicy lead that came in. And once we figure something out,
I'm going to hand it over to you as well. Like just that little incentive, don't go and send it to
them, you know, um, without using it as a carrot. So, um, and how much do you spend? You sent them
four or five total. Once you got the deal, how much did it cost you to get those five?
It's over a hundred bucks. So actually I started the campaign two weeks ago. Uh, this campaign's
been killing it. Like I struck a real good area. The due diligence was awesome. Uh, I actually had
four leads coming in four days. I had a business owner hooked, got him on a closing call. Uh,
wasn't able to close him because I missed one of the steps, but, uh, he just didn't have money.
Really? He really wasn't somebody who I could really work with. Anyways, a lead comes in the
very next day, got another business owner hooked. And I think four leads came in the very next four
days. So this thing moved so quick, uh, got this guy scheduled. So probably just over 200 bucks
total on this whole campaign had been spent before I closed a business owner. I love it, bro.
Even if you'd spent, I know some people get it out there, like I spent 200 bucks, whatever.
Even if it costs you 500, heaven forbid it costs you 500 because you didn't get that one. You had
to do two more, three more ads weren't working guys. Even if it costs you 500 bucks, as soon as
you make that first thousand dollars. And what I do is if I do, I always do weekly, but I try to
on the first payment at the very first month, I try to get the whole payment upfront just to make
sure like I they're good to go and they can pay a thousand bucks. You just recoup all your costs.
And now you made an extra 500 bucks on top of it, even if you spend $500. So don't give up on these,
these deals. Sometimes it costs a little bit of money, but you recoup your costs immediately.
So, um, okay. So you spent about 200 bucks on ads. Um, and, and this campaign went quick and
not all campaigns go quick guys. So don't be like, well, that'd be nice. Yeah, of course.
Some of the other deals you might get a lead today and it might take a week for the second one to
come in. Just don't put yourself in a corner and say, Hey, I'm going to get you four leads in five
days. Just say, I'm going to get you a couple of leads. It's going to take, it could take a few
days. It could take a week or two. I'm just, I want to just let you test a few of these out.
I want to get you really good ones. And then we're going to talk. Is that cool? Just don't
put yourself in a corner with expectations because we can't really control how these campaigns do.
So, and then my other question was going to be how many business owners you go through something
sounds like you went through two, right? Yeah, two total. That one, this concrete one that I just,
you know, I'm still going to, I'm going to put this one on the shelf, but what I did is like,
I kind of get pissed off when people do stuff like that, if I get ghosts or anything.
So I was just like, do you know what, dude, I'm going to go set up two more campaigns.
So I kept that one running, went up, went and set up two more campaigns. So I got two campaigns
running, uh, separate from that other one, just cause I was pissed. I was like, dude,
I'm going to get you back. But anyways, that one, uh, that one's been running for over three days.
I've got three business owners, uh, and it's just, it's just a matter of time before I find
somebody who's hungry because the leads are coming in. So somebody's going to want the
lead. Somebody's going to want to grow. Oh yeah. That's the, that's the right mentality.
And that's also good that you said that because I think some people might hear your other story
about tree service and think like, well, it always goes good for Jason, of course,
but that's not the case. And sometimes that happens. And sometimes maybe out of those three
people he's already been through, maybe the second one he messed up and that should have been the one
he got and he didn't. And now he's got to go. And I will just tell you that my mentality is
that if there are leads coming through, whether it's with add organically, there is always,
always, always a deal to be had. Do not ever give up on it. Whether we have to go into a different
niche that also does that, whether we have to go into another city that covers that one,
whatever the case is, if you are getting leads, there's always a deal to be had. So don't ever
give up on it. Okay. Um, this is an important question. I want to ask you, Jason, what,
what doubts did you have coming into this business? And also not everyone know that
you had to sell your truck to get into this business. Yeah. So when I heard the price,
I was like, Oh shit. I'm like, Oh boy. But I, I, I knew, I knew that it was either this or go back
to the nine to five, to be honest, because, and I was not going back to nine to five. And I,
I've been in this for long enough to realize that, or just in digital marketing in general,
that this business model makes so much sense. I was like, this has to be where it's at.
I control the assets. Somebody walks away from me. I maintain everything. They can't just take what
all of this hard work that I built up and just run off with it. You know what I'm saying? Um,
so the one doubt that I had when I came in wasn't necessarily the price because I knew the business
model worked. It was my capability of selling the deals because I'm not a salesman. I struggle
communicating sometimes. And, um, I was kind of doubting my capability of doing what you did
because with all of your sales experience, um, but I just went in there with, with trust that
you knew you were talking about and got to work. Have you noticed that we don't hardly ever have,
like me and Aaron, we're talking about this. I would say 95% of people that come into this
business, into this group, do not have sales experience. And have you noticed the, the,
how few times you hear people talk about not being able to sell? Aaron, you told me, we knew,
and I talked about this, you remember this? Yeah. What's crazy is that like, I mean, generally
speaking, you think sales is the most difficult part and it's the most important part. It's part
that most people struggle at, but with the specific process of what we do, specifically the
results in advance, it's like it's taken the skill out of sales. Obviously the more skill that you
have, the less reps it's going to take. But again, it is a formula. Like if you do 10 prospecting
calls, you're probably going to get one hook. If you do three hooks, you're probably going to get
one zoom call. If you two, three zoom calls, maybe four, you're probably going to get a close.
So, yeah. 100%. It's, it's amazing because I mean, I've been, I was in these other groups
and nobody could sell. I had to have somebody, somebody DM me just the other day. And from
another course I was part of and they're like, yeah, I gave this business model a go. This person
literally said, I have no problem getting leads and ranking websites. I just can't do the sales.
And I'm like, dude, that's the part in my group, in digital landlords, everybody gets deals.
If anything, it's sometimes finding the right business owner or tweaking the ads or whatever,
but like, we have no problem doing that. So anyway, it's just, it's interesting because when
I started this, that was the biggest issue and we've kind of like removed that entire obstacle.
And it's not we, it's the fact that when you send results in advance, you don't have to really sell.
So that's, that's the truth. So, okay. What's your why, Jason?
Jason. Family, really creating, creating it, you know, you only live once. So creating a life
worth living for. I don't, I don't want to spend 80% of my life away from my kids. If you include
sleeping and stuff like that, like I want to, I want to spend my time with my family. And I,
you know, I grew up with my, my dad just working all the time. Like, you, you know, he loves you,
but you didn't get to see him very often because he was always working, building his business.
And if I could build my business, maybe even homeschool my kids, like I would love that.
That's something that that's a life I'm striving for just to spend time with my family, to be honest.
Would you say you're driven by like, are you motivated to succeed or are you driven by
insecurity? Oh, I'm motivated to succeed. I, I can now see that I'm capable of reaching
a hundred thousand dollars a month based off of what, you know, like this, I wouldn't have had
this confidence if I had never joined digital networks. If I was hanging out with a free group,
just leeching off of other people, trying to get information out of them, I would have never had
the confidence to figure this out. But because I've practiced what you've taught me and it's
proven to be true. And it's I've seen the results from it. I'm already at $13,000 a month. Like,
where will I be in the next 12 months? I think I could honestly scale this to
30 or $50,000 within the next 12 months. Assuming I bring on the right team. But
well, here's what I look at, bro, is you're at, let's just, I'm going to say to say 14K
to make easy math, but like, this is what happened with me when I got my first deal.
And I remember getting a thousand dollars a month and going, dude, I just have to do that
100 more times. Like, which is a lot, but I saw a clear path. And so like doing what you've done,
I just took a hundred thousand divided by 14,000. Like if you do it seven more times or six more
times, plus the one that you have, like you're at a hundred, you're making money that people go to
school for their whole life and they don't make. And it's crazy. Like it's literally in your hands
to go make a million dollars a year doing, renting piece of crap websites.
It's crazy. Yeah. It's, it almost feels like you're, you're scamming the system, right?
I was talking to a guy the other day. He was saying how he went to school for seven years
for his occupation and he's making $80,000 a year.
And I'm sitting there like, Oh dude, like, honestly, I don't really do anything. Like if I
think about it, like I look at this as a game, I feel like I'm playing a game all day long where
like, I'm like, Oh yeah, I got a lead. Let's go. I call this business owner. And I know that I have
all those value that I'm bringing to the table. And if he tells me, no, I'll just give him kind
of like a smart aleck response and just kind of be like, okay, that's okay, dude. Like I'll just
call up your competition and just hand it to him. It's no big deal. You know, just to let them kind
of think about it on the way out. Yeah. It's true, bro. Yeah. When you, when you start to see that
there is a clear path, like I think when you get to 10,000 and 1520 and you're like, okay, I think
I can actually do this. It becomes very exciting because for some reason we always think it's for
everybody else, but not for us. And I had this conversation with a friend of mine who's a real
estate agent. And I think he's going to be joining this soon because he's been just kind of seeing
some stuff. He sees I'm always traveling and he's like, he's big in the real estate. He's in Vegas.
He'd been doing this for a long time. He's very serious about it, professional. He does his stuff.
He reads his books. He does. And he's like, he kind of was asking me like, what, what I make
and everything. And he's like, what, what? And you're in Dubai and like all the, you know, and
yeah, dude, it's, and I told him, he's like, wait, so you made seven figures in 2020s. Like you've
made seven figures. And I'm like, yeah. And I told him this, once you make seven figures in a year,
it like changes your identity because you can't make a million dollars and go back to being
less than a million. It's like, you are now a seven figure guy, a seven figure gal.
And come hell or high water, you are going to do it. And guys, since I made that $100,000 a month,
like that's just who we are. Like as a company, as a person, like I will never ever, ever go below
seven figures in a year. Like it just, it's just who I, what I am. It's like my standard has been
raised. And so anyway, dude, Jason, I have no doubt you're going to hit a hundred thousand per month.
But also I want to point out in the air, I'll probably tell you the same thing
is you can tell like when you could tell why Jason's successful because Jason has,
he's got that energy. He's excited. Like if Jason was talking to me about leads,
I would be excited to work with Jason. If Jason was talking to me as a friend about doing this
business model, I would be excited about doing this business model because I can hear the excitement
in his voice. And it's as a reminder guys, sales, the transfer of energy. And some of you guys are
sitting there calling and you sound like you're, I would rather watch paint dry on a wall than
listen to your sorry ass talk about this business. And sometimes you've got to be excited. I tell
Francesca this every time she gets on a phone, on a sales call, because she does the sales for our
agency now, which by the way has been amazing because I don't have to do that anymore.
But I'm like Francesca, just remember sales are the transfer of energy. And if you're excited
about it, they're going to be excited about it. If you're dull about it, they're going to be dull
about it. And so you guys can hear it in Jason's voice. He's so excited about it. He's, it's a game
it's, it's whatever. So that's huge. And some of you guys don't have that right now and you need
to get that. So, Jason, for time's sake, we're going to cut it right there. I think we need to
do a part two. I think we also should maybe bless everyone in the free group and just do a random
look, go live and let people hear your story. But congrats on your success. I know you're just
getting started. I'm not surprised with your success, but I'm also proud of you, bro. So keep
it up. Thanks, man. Hey, I just wanted to ask you one question real quick. So you played
basketball for Pera one, right? Yeah. What are you going to ask me? Yeah, dude. So I, I played
for Juab and we played against you guys when I was in high school. I think you're a few years
Okay, go ahead. I didn't know that. You know, some other podunk high school, you know,
no, so you're, so you're, you're from Nephi. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So that school is way bigger
than mine, by the way. It's like, I'd way rather be from Nephi. No kidding. Go ahead. Ask me.
Anyways, dude, I'm like, my dude, if, if Pera one's so small, I like went in and like looked at max
preps, you know, like the high school and I like found all the wood brothers and like, dude,
like they were like, you guys were probably the jocks back in the day, weren't you?
Yeah. I mean, we had, what else do you do in Pera one?
That's just awesome. I just wanted to bring that up. Well, I'll say this by the way,
because everyone will know Porter, me, Zach hands down, Porter was the best athlete out of all of
us. So he, you guys, you guys can always bring that up. Porter can always hold that over our heads.
So Porter was definitely, but also just so Porter can be humbled. He also was terrible until he'd
tell about his junior senior year. He was like, dude, is this kid like, it's a little slow, like
mentally, like he was just a little bit of a late bloomer, but he was really good as a senior. So
I was probably the worst out of all three of us. So that's why I'm really trying to take this
making money thing seriously and just kind of put them in their place. I'm just kidding. But yeah,
anyway, so yeah, just long story short, small towns, podunk towns, dude, my high school,
I don't even think it's accredited. I don't think, I think if you went back to the teachers,
not all of them, but there was a couple of teachers, I know they didn't have college degrees.
We had teachers sneaking out in the middle of class, like pretending to go to their car.
We'd catch them out smoking fricking whatever out, like not joints, but like cigarettes and
in the green house, like teachers, students, teacher relationships. I mean, dude, the weirdest
stuff that was like completely normal to me, but completely inappropriate. So if somebody from
high school like me or Porter can make this work. Yeah, dude, you have no excuse or juap. Let's be
honest. Anyway, thanks for coming on, Jason. We'll talk soon. Yeah. See you guys.